and you're live chairman thank you very
much
thank you very much good evening
everyone and welcome to
this council meeting my name is
councillor mark hurd and i'm the
chairman of malden district council
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect
in 2020 on the 4th of april in response
to the kovic 19 situation
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving consent
to being recorded and i also
uh welcome our local government
association colleagues who are present
to observe this evening's meeting so
welcome to you
members could i ask everyone present in
this meeting to ensure your microphone
is muted we're not addressing the
council
this reduces background noises and
unintentional disturbances
during each item members please use the
hands up function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak i will then invite you at the
appropriate
time members are reminded that apart
from indicating points of order or that
you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose when
speaking and referring to the agenda
papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
please ensure you turn on your
microphone when you speak
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting
to introduce themselves starting with mr
dodson
[Music]
good evening members paul dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance
thank you mr dodson mr holmes
good evening members richard holmes
structure service delivery
thank you mr leslie
good evening i'm chris leslie director
of resources
thank you uh this is emma holmes
good evening chair it's emma holmes
senior legal specialist and deputy
monitoring officer
thank you mr lee
good evening members i'm matthew lee
lead specialist place
and chief planning officer here at
morton district council thank you
thank you mr butcher good evening
members stephen butcher commercial
manager
thank you and miss bird good evening
shaman good evening members tara bird on
the committee club for this evening's
meeting thank you
thank you very much are there any other
offices present please
okay thank you uh um miss bird please
can we now have a roll call of members
to
confirm who is in attendance thank you
yes terry members if you could just
indicate you're here when i call your
name please
starting with councillor bassinger
please good evening everyone i'm
president thank you
thank you councilman present
brian beale good evening present
councillor bell good evening everybody
i'm here
councillor boyce present
council mrs channel
hello um good evening everyone i'm
president tara thank you very much thank
you very much thank you
cancer durham present
leaving everyone present so mrs fleming
president tara thank you thank you
freaker
president obviously
president tara thank you councillor
jarvis
evening tara chairman members good
evening councillor keys
good evening members evening everybody
mitara present
good evening thank you cancer lagging
hey good evening
good night our present thank you
councillor mays
good evening tara present counselor
morris
councillor maurice
i think you've lost cancerous
yes good evening sarah good evening
everyone present thank you
councillor shawnee good evening everyone
leaving tara present thank you
councillor siddall
good evening tara i'm present you
councillor schemes
good evening everybody hi tara here
good evening tara chairman members
officers i'm present
evening thank you cancer stilts good
evening everyone i'm present
thank you cancer swain yes good evening
present tara
thank you council mrs thompson oh good
evening everyone
present yes thank you thank you cats for
this white
good evening tara i'm present thank you
thank you
and i believe council morris is back
online council maurice is that right
can you just confirm you're in
attendance please
chairman i can see he's online but we're
obviously having problems hearing him
but thank you that's the role cool
okay um perhaps you'd let me know when
we're able to make uh
contact of course chairman thank you uh
agenda item
number two is apologies for absence may
i have the apologies for absence please
uh yes chairman apologies we received
from cancer juric and we have been
advised that council morley is hoping to
join the meeting a little late
thank you very much thank you that's
noted
agenda item number three is declaration
of interest
this is to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive
of the code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should that
need arise
throughout the meeting if any member has
an interest to declare
please use the hands up function now to
indicate
and i will invite you to speak
tara can you please advise if any member
has indicated a wish to speak
oh yes chairman councillor durham
council boyce and council mrs channel
have indicated they wish to speak
thank you thank you councillor darren
thank you chairman um i have a
non-binary interest as a member of essex
county council
so any item on today's agenda pertaining
to that organization thank you
thank you very much councillor boyce
sorry chairman did you ask for me
did you have a declaration that you
wanted to declare
um the agenda item in pnc
um as an arms house
trustee i may have a non-pecuniary
interest
thank you thank you councillor boyce
councillor chana thank you chairman
um chairman um non-pecuniary i'm also a
member of essex county council
so any matter within the reports that
refer to it but
i would say uh that i can see at the
moment but anything i
um is mentioned sort of in a
surreptitious way so it's
uh determined item number 10 certainly
number 12
13 um
uh 16 chairman um
and then also some of the pnc items um
which i can't name and then also
regarding a pnc item like councillor
boyce i must declare
um i think it may be non-pecuniary i'm a
trustee of
arms house charity chairman thank you
thank you very much that are there any
other members with declarations
chairman councillor helm councillor i'm
sorry i couldn't see your hand
counselor helm
right we're there i'm also a member of
uh arms house charity thank you
thank you very much and uh just for the
record
uh i'm also a trustee of
um a local charity the joseph henry
unwin
uh charity which has provided money to
all the food banks in malden
and that is on a gender item number 10
non-pecuniary
agenda item 4 is the minutes
from the 4th of february and it's
recommended that the minutes
of the meeting held on this date and
they're found on pages
7 to 14 are approved as a true
and accurate record iso move if you wish
to second that motion so we can discuss
the minutes
uh please switch on your microphone and
state your name now
councillor maze councillor maze thank
you very much if any member wishes to
raise any
matter of accuracy please use the hands
up function
and i'll invite you to speak counselor
channel
um yes thank you chairman um were you
going to go through the pages or do you
just want me to say
the matter of accuracy uh i will go
through the pages
um unless uh unless you don't well i'll
start i know the page it's on
uh if that helps chairman i wasn't quite
sure if you were going to go through or
how you wanted me to do it
now i'll go through the pages so page
seven
page eight page nine
page ten page eleven
yes chairman please yeah it's page 11
and 12 actually
it runs over and i do apologize chairman
i did send um
an email um to the committee clerks and
yourself and i apologize i put the wrong
minute number
um but it's two four five and it's
questions to the leader of the council
and it has got one question down that i
did as chairman but i did ask another
question
and that's not recorded and that
question regarding to the leader about
did you agree with me
about the protocol of the council should
be followed
in public meetings and members should
address officers in accordance
uh with the rules agreed by council i
couldn't see that recorded in the
minutes chairman so
i'm just following what we've been told
to do to give prior notice but i
apologize it was a bit late because
um it was only when i read it just ahead
of the meeting i it sort of jumped out
at me james i do apologize
so you're you're saying that there is an
omission
yes chairman one question i asked is in
the minutes recorded but i couldn't see
that one chairman
okay um i think um mr bird are we able
to check the tape
and uh um
uh decide whether that is uh correct or
not
yes of course gentlemen we can do that
no problem at all thank you very much
chairman i can assure you it is correct
because i have checked the tape myself
but okay i understand
we can add that in german that's no
problem thank you very much
uh anything else on page 12.
age 13 and page 14
iso move can they be agreed by a cent
agreed to
so thank you very much
we move on now to agenda item five
these are the minutes from the 23rd of
february
and it's recommended that these minutes
uh
found on pages 15 to 34 are approved as
a true and accurate record
i moved to discuss those minutes if you
wish to second that motion
please state your name now councillor
mays
thank you councillor mays does any
member wish to raise
any matter of accuracy uh on these
minutes of the 23rd of february i'll go
through them page 15
page 16 17
page 18 page 19.
page 20 page 21
22 23
24 25
page 26 page 27
page 28 page 29
page 30 page 31
32 is blank and
33 and 34.
are you prepared to agree those by
ascent grade three
agreed
[Music]
thank you members the next item
um
is a later item i'm just just getting
that up now
[Music]
so
so we move on then to agenda item number
six which is
public questions uh in accordance
with the council's public participation
scheme i can advise that we've received
the following questions
question from mr d sismi his question is
what feedback has the council leader
received from the monitoring officer
regarding the council's budget press
statement on the 25th of february
and what regard did the council give to
section 2
of the local government act prior to its
publication
does a leader think it is a justifiable
use of council taxpayers money
to use the council press office to make
partisan
political points despite the provisions
of the local government act
in accordance with the procedure there
will be no discussion on questions
um put unless it's formally moved and
agreed that the subject matter
should be referred to a committee again
without
discussion leader please can you respond
to the question
certainly once the question from mr
sismi was submitted
after the deadline of two clear working
days before tonight's meeting
i am happy to provide a response the
monitoring officer provided feedback
on the leader's budget statement and
whilst he did not believe
it contravened section 2 of the local
government act
he did advise it should be amended and
this action was taken
and the press release re-issued i can
confirm that the council reviews
all publications and press releases
paying regard to section two of the
local government act
prior to them being released and where
necessary advice is sought from the
monitoring officer thank you chairman
thank you very much i'll move on to
agenda item
7 chairman's announcements
well members it's a year today since
malden district council requested
that all staff work from home
temporarily
to address concerns regarding kobit 19
and to ensure that we were taking the
right approach
to ensure the safety of our staff
you may remember that earlier that week
one year ago
we had an emergency meeting of the
council to establish
interim arrangements for managing the
organisation
whilst council meetings could not be
held in the chamber
this set council in good stead the
challenges
we would face and i'm very proud of the
way that the council has responded
one year on i think it is appropriate to
reflect upon the past year
which has brought unprecedented changes
uh challenges and also brought out the
best
from both malden district council and
the communities we serve and work
together with
and as we take stock on the year i would
like to take this opportunity
to thank all of our staff at malden
district council for their hard work
and commitment over the past year for
keeping our services
flowing and thereby supporting our
residents and businesses
i also thank our partners who have come
together
to work with us including the malden cvs
community groups
and all of our residents for their
support
i'd also like to thank the nhs not only
for the care that they have provided
but also for the efficient and rapid
rollout of the life-saving vaccine
which i'm certain is our way back to
some normality
through the course of this year
finally i'd like to take a moment to
reflect
that many people have lost friends and
family to the covid epidemic
and i ask you to join me in a minutes
silence
as we remember those who we have lost
and those who are still slowly
recovering from
this illness
thank you very much indeed members
um other
chairman announcements uh there was a
a charity chocolate tasting event which
uh was
very kindly attended uh in wolf and
for the london borough of waltham forest
by
the vice chairman councillor carly mays
thank you very much indeed for that
councillor maze
agenda item number eight is
the minute book this is the performance
governance
and audit committee on the 25th of
february 2021
these are found on pages 35 to 40.
councillor mrs stiltz to present the
minutes please
thank you mr chairman and chairman
members of the council
i present the minutes of the performance
governance and audit committee held
remotely
on the 25th of february 2021
these are found on pages 35 to 40
and i propose their reception and
adoption
iso move can i have a seconder
job thank you
they are on pages 35
36. 37
38 39
and 40 is a blank page
iso move thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor stilts um um
nobody has indicated that they wish to
speak
um i think um councillor stilts we can
agree those by ascent
thank you very much
agenda item number nine is minutes of
meetings of the council and this is to
note that since the last meeting of the
council
and up until wednesday the 10th of march
the committees listed have met and to
receive any
questions in accordance with council and
committee procedure
rule 6 2. if any member wishes to raise
a question in relation to the minutes of
this meeting
please make this known by using the
hands up function within this meeting
tara has anyone indicated they wish to
speak please
no chairman nobody has thank you
[Music]
thank you very much um i'm satisfied
then that no
members wish to speak and hopefully you
are happy to
agree those by ascent agreed agreed
agreed
thank you very much
we now move to agenda item 10
notice of motion uh miss burke can we be
uh do we know if uh councillor morris is
with us
a chairman he's on the call yes he's got
his camera on
okay you can hear me thank you
thank you thank you okay so we move then
to a notice of motion agenda item number
10
in accordance with notice duly given
under procedure rule 4
council of morris to move the following
motion
duly seconded by council of bell
councilor morris
are you able to read out your motion
please
um i certainly am chairman thank you um
in view of the current difficulties our
community faces
modern district council pledges to
operate a food bank
to help the vulnerable people of our
district
that will be located within the council
offices
in malden as well as any suitable
location
at burnham on crouch as soon as possible
thank you thank you um
councillor bell and seconder do you wish
to add anything
i don't mr chairman i think council
morris has
summed it up thank you thank you very
much i will now
invite members to make any comments um
on the motion again please use your
hands up
function tara has anybody indicated that
they wish to speak
um yes chairman i've got councillor mays
councillor durham council mrs channel
council voice counselor
bill miss bill sorry thank you
okay um i think i got most most of those
councillor mays first thank you mr
chairman
members this district already has a full
network
of food banks community fridges and food
hubs
councillors have been working hard with
a number of partners including cvs
uh the cafe at saint peter's the
salvation army
and both haybridge and malden parish
councils
on how to protect and enhance the
current provision for the direct benefit
of those in our community who need it
this has been going on since last year
and throughout the pandemic
to date the council's already supported
the uh the implementation of a funding
uh sorry the funding of a community
storage unit
um which is actually run by modern
community volunteer service
who have also introduced very recently a
new referral system
for emergency provision across the
district for all our partners to use
i myself have actually used this
particular referral system and it works
a treat
joshua fulcher strategic team lead
community strategy policy and
communications has spearheaded
much of this work on behalf of the
council already
his knowledge gained in manchester of
food banks and their provision
has made the council a key component in
multi-agency discussions
that are in progress at the moment with
partners and stakeholders
about the services on offer to our
community
grant funding from the elc
has provided additional resources to our
communities resulting in
196 food hampers at christmas
and a very staggering 567 hampers
uh through the the months of january and
february
this amounts to a total worth of ten
over ten thousand pounds
uh additional food for residents who are
in need
and is a top-up to the existing network
that we already have
this has continued through march and
will continue further into april
and early may and will be of a similar
if not even higher level
as a result of this ongoing work and the
number of partners and stakeholders that
are already uh
involved in this multi-agency approach i
would like to make the following most
uh amendment to the motion
in view of the current difficulties our
community faces
malden district council pledges to
continue working with outside agencies
to identify and support our existing
food banks
whilst investigating whether more food
banks are needed within the district
this support may include offering
assistance by a website publicity
as well as promoting a multi-agency
approach to our community needs
do i have a seconder i'll second that
thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor mays so we have an
amended
uh an amended motion on the table
uh councillor durham
thank you very much chairman um
chairman um i will be supporting this
motion and
voting against the amendment for a
couple of very good reasons in my view
i support this totally because food
banks have become
a fact of life and provide food for
those most in need
all of us here are fortunate enough to
have adequate food for our needs but it
cannot be said for everybody
for whatever reason we all know the
pandemic has had a significant impact on
families
and once furloughing it's later this
year
many more people are likely to lose
their jobs through no fault of their own
but food poverty is not only a covered
matter and there will always be a need
for some people
to need this valuable support
i recognized this myself with the uh
winter hardship fund from essex county
council and was very pleased to be able
to give 1500 pounds
in haybridge to pay for christmas
hampers but also funding to set
up the new haybridge food bank which is
an excellent
uh an excellent project i'm not sure
the practicalities of using the council
building
but there is a very good reason why it
should be considered
members we have the citizens of ice
bureau we have the police we have job
serve we have
all of these various organizations
in what has become a hub for the town
i remember very clearly mr holmes saying
to me one day
that he'd spoken to a lady who was in
tears in our reception
and she was overwhelmed by the fact
that she could visit just one venue
and address all of her issues in respect
of benefits
she was able to see the police and get
advice from the cab i think
that having this central hub if we can
find somewhere in the council offices
or even if it is a satellite to another
food
another food bank i think it would be a
really
really good thing and i totally support
uh this motion as it stands
and i congratulate uh the member for for
bringing this
uh to the council tonight thank you
thank you very much councillor bill
thank you mr chairman numb
crikey i must admit i'm actually sitting
here now feeling a little bit
foolish because i clearly hadn't done my
due diligence
on this issue before i seconded the
motion
and i really wasn't aware that all this
work
involving counsellors involving officers
was already going on let alone the
number of food banks
that were available in the community
however this clearly throws up
an issue that we don't know about what
the things that already are going on in
the work that is already being done
which but that's another another thing
for another time
and i find myself in a position here
because
the most important thing for me is
supporting
our vulnerable communities but the
second
most important thing for me is
empowering
those communities to help themselves
and if this is going
to step on that an impact on that
then it goes against
it goes against my values to be quite
honest
and my other concern as well is really
it
is relating to um
to outputs and outcomes now councillor
shannon and i were having a conversation
i think yesterday
about how the important thing is
outcomes
and not outputs and if we are already
on the way to achieving what we aim to
which is food relief for the vulnerable
in our community
then it seems we're doing it with
few with less out less in the way of
output
bearing in mind that residents are
residents sorry offices are
really under the cash at the moment so
members i'm i'm i'm
inclined to support the amendment
because it seems the sensible
most efficient most effective way
to ensure that our communities needs are
met in in the best way possible that's
the important thing for me
and i would hate hate for
any of the community organizations
sorry that currently been involved in
this work to feel offended by what we're
doing
thank you all right thank you very much
um
tara i'm sorry i didn't quite catch the
other speakers
no problem chairman and nextest
counselor mrs channer
and then councillor morris and there's a
few more other that are advised perhaps
once you've done those too if that makes
it easier for you german
sorry did um sorry did miss bird did you
say earlier council of boyce wanted to
speak
no chairman
um well chairman um again
i actually do have a great
um if you'd like um pontiac to support
um the motion to a degree um the
principle of it
um but really it's the practicalities i
guess that um
i i'm thinking about with the council
offices i'm not quite sure
how um that would work or where the food
bank would be operating from
but i i'm very much a supporter of the
food banks and i will declare being an
essex county councillor
es6 has done a lot of work and all the
um issues that uh
council amaze i won't now readdress
those because she's more or less
highlighted what i was going to be
saying
in terms of the food banks and i am
aware there's a
food bank in um burnham as well i think
that operates out of a
church as far as i know and also south
minster i actually give um some food to
the south minster bank
and that feeds in into burnham so albeit
i've got something
in principle with the motion it's the
practicalities
and there is a lot of work going on by
all those names so it's really how we
make the best most efficient way
and to ensure we are actually making
sure all of
the vulnerable people and families and
i'm aware of them very much in my
division and also
my district council ward um so
yes that's what i wanted to say i have
great sympathies and the principle
of the food bank motion and i wanted to
support they now have heard the
amendment
um that's brought into the equation um
some very good thinking and i would be
interested i don't know if we can do
this chairman about the practicalities
how would it run having a food bank in
the council offices but when we have got
light club there where they've got the
vaccination center
um the cab um and other bodies is it a
feasibility you know
that it could operate i don't know about
times opening up and everything
like that chairman so thank you thank
you very much um
councillor morris although your um
your motion was the first one of course
you are quite entitled to talk on this
amendment
thank you very much chairman i think it
probably would be uh better for the
chamber if i uh wait to hear what
everyone's got to say
and then come back because uh there are
some um
you know there's a lot of here a lot of
what i'm hearing so far
um are assumptions and i have actually
got the information
that the members are are asking for so i
probably better if i
just note that all the members are
saying and then come back at the end if
that's okay with you yes
yes that's fine thank you very much
councillor logan
cancer lagging
no i'm sorry i don't have my hand up all
right
okay i've got cancer swaying next then
council mrs thompson
cancer freaker cancer boyce cancer
durham council stills
thank you so council swain is next
chairman
councillor swain thank you uh
yes thank you chairman um just referring
to um
what both council government councillor
chandler has said there is a difference
between
a food bank and the other essentially
personal
um activities of the cib police or
whatever
the food bank is a very much a logistics
um space consuming activity
um but to get to the main points
um there are two key things about food
banks
one is there they are uh essentially
voluntary
and they um are a
good example of community involvement in
uh supporting each other
um and that is what we should build on
the other thing is that they have to be
local
um so for accessibility to people
and it's a little bit simplistic to just
focus on malden burnham back south in mr
um and hey bridge there will be other
people who
need the services of a food bank spread
out around the villages and around the
the district there there is an issue
there of how one contacts them but that
is to use the existing
um food banks and uh in
provide us putting a in touch with b
and the best way for doing that is
through local contacts
to the voluntary groups or through
parish councils um
the uh motionless put
and this is why i would support the
amendment is that
we want to support we don't want to try
and manage
and we don't want the district council
trying to provide a um
a management structure to try and
control and and order all these
this is just be creating an unnecessary
bureaucracy which
is um sort of antipathetic to the
voluntary nature of
what has been going on so i think we
should focus on uh building on the
existing network of uh
food banks encouraging new ones if
people wish to set them up
but the kind of support that would be
needed will vary from one group to
another
and this is why one doesn't want to try
and
regiment um activities
um so um
i would very much support the amendment
to this motion
i think i think it's um much more
realistic
it supports what's going on and
obviously a lot has been going on
is going on uh and we should work find
out
from the food banks how we can help them
thank you very much
sorry i've got i've got to stop you
there because we have got other speakers
thank you councillor thompson
thank you chairman um yeah i'd rather
think i'm with council
swain on this he picked the very word
which i was groping
for and that's bureaucracy what most of
all although
absolutely i support the idea and the
principle
but i really wouldn't want to spend
resource on duplicating existing
effort that would be silly we need to
put whatever resource we can and i
don't know what that is yet into
actually you know providing people with
what they need
and the other thing it does strike me
that the um
the in-house one requires a report to
council and therefore that's not cons
be speedy whatever we do so i'm very
inclined to support the amendment i
think it would be the quickest way to
help even if we move on to do something
else later
i think having a satellite might be a
very good idea
um but again we're looking at a report
to council and
people want the help now so so far until
i hear what everyone else has to say
i think i'm with the amendment because
whatever we've got we could use to help
other people really rather quickly thank
you
thank you councillor thompson uh
councillor fluker
thank you chairman um look i've
supported
density food pantry ever since it
started i think that's what you're
referring to as south west because a lot
of people notice the south amends the
one
and look you know these people do a huge
amount of work and it works incredibly
well
and uh but my my concern about this and
coming from
a slightly different angle chairman is
it so it's great having lots of food
banks but can you really
get enough donations to sustain them and
then if you
calm then it means that you you you
spread the resources very thin
and then you may find that some people
might not what
might not get what they actually need
and that is my concern chairman but i
agree with all the other comments that
have been made about this
uh and and that's all i say for the
moment thank you
thank you very much uh just uh
just as as an aside uh it's not so much
the donations but it's certainly
volunteers that uh
these food banks need um
miss bird can you tell me how has that
is that i've got another hand on my
screen but i can't see who it is for
another speaker
chairman i've got a few more members a
councillor boyce then councillor durham
cancer stilts and councillor hull and
then i'll see council morris to come
back at the end
thank you okay thank you uh councillor
don i know that you've already spoken
uh on this amendment uh i'm going to go
next to councillor boyce
um thank you chairman um i i tried to
get in
uh at the beginning um
um because what i'm hearing in this
debate
is why the system was set up of motions
being referred
to a relevant committee so an officer's
report can be produced
on it and all the issues considered
at that time i
i'm quite happy to support either the
motion
or the amendment in itself but
i do believe that perhaps another
amendment on whatever
becomes a substantive motion um to
actually refer
this because all the issues although
councilman morris says he's got all the
answers
i suspect he hasn't uh and i i
think that at the end of the day we will
need
um some officer input into uh
advising on this issue
trying to deliver a scheme
at the council meeting is trying to
describe a horse and end up with a camel
thank you chairman all right thank you
councillor voice councillor stilts
thank you mr chairman i
i've listened to what everyone says and
i am in complete agreement with
um some of the things that have been
said we're not trying to say we don't
want a third bank we don't
we we think that you know but the the
best things to do are to support the
ones that are already there
there's already a food hub at staple
there's already the food bank at
southminster there's
three food providers in malden we've got
the elam church we've got the salvation
army
and we've got the the cafe
and we've got the food that's been done
by haybridge parish council and malden
town council all being supported by
essex county council
so i think when we're looking at it what
our biggest thing is
we don't think it should be done in the
council offices
we think we should be helping those food
banks that already exist
to be able to give out more food to the
people
that need it thank you mr chair
thank you councillor stilts councillor
hull
thank you very much simon um i i deal
with quite a few people that
have these food hampers and they're
really great and they're really grateful
but my attitude is if if we kind of try
and
teach these people to either grow their
own vegetables
and food or whatever and um and trying
to teach them to cook
and how you know that is a big point of
it also
um that was just my point thank you
thank you very much um other than
councilman morris
uh are there any other speakers tara
and chairman um
already spoken on the amendment
counsellor darren so i'm not going to
allow you to kind of
unless you want to clarify something
chairman yes i do want to clarify uh
because of
things i've heard thank you very much
for your indulgence
chairman nobody has said that this is
this this is not short-term this is a
long-term requirement
the vaccination center won't be there
forever it probably won't be there after
september
and we're going to have a building where
there's lots of room unallocated
and i go back to my original point and
say that the
council office is a very central hub
it's also completely surrounded by
domestic dwellings a lot of old people
in flats probably some
some food bank users and nobody has said
that it can't be
staffed by volunteers i'm sure there are
lots of volunteers
more than happy to uh
to come and help and in terms of
distribution remember chairman
we have the viking bus faced at the
council offices that goes all over the
denji
and the viking drivers are voluntary so
we already have a voluntary service
operating
out of our council offices so it makes
perfect sense
because the viking bus potentially could
be used to deliver an outreach service
so chairman i i'm afraid that i i
disagree
uh with a lot of the other other uh
speakers because i
feel that the council offices if there
is sufficient room
is a perfectly good location chairman
on just one final point i should have
declared an interest
um in in my uh funding for the haybridge
food bank
but i'm also an ambassador for the
country food trust which
uh distributes free meals to the food
bank so i
i apologize for for missing that earlier
all right
thank you very much and and finally
councillor morris
thank you chairman um i've got quite a
bit to say i'll try and get money
destroyed
[Music]
miss field
thank you chairman um i'm i'm all in
agreement with all of this
um and i am airing on the side of the
amendment but i'd really like to know
what's
i'd like to hear from uh councillor
morris what sort of
resources is he does he say that the
council can provide
okay thank you very much so um
councillor morris uh so it's your turn
now to speak but you do have three
minutes please
thank you very much is there anyone else
that needs uh any more information
i thought there was another council that
was waiting to speak
no they've already spoken so i'll go to
you next
time clarification
chairman um councillor chana actually
wanted to speak and with all due respect
you allowed councillor durham to come
back so it's only fair that you allow
councillor chana to speak
and i possibly would like to speak
depending
if i'm allowed after councillor morris
thank you chad
application
said he's got the information i think i
alluded to earlier
i wanted to know how the council could
do i made the point about the cab but
could the council do it
councilmember said he's got that
information but i don't know
uh chairman if an officer can assist but
i'm um
you know i i agree with lots of things
everyone said and i said i've got
sympathies with emotion i've heard the
amen which i think is very sensible
actually
hearing everything now and i think what
counselor boyce actually said
is extremely sensible um because
obviously
the way this discussion is going um i
think everyone has got um
leaning to obviously the food bank
proposal but recognizing there's a lot
going on
as well and just to say the other food
banks home starts involved in some of
the food
for vulnerable families as well and they
do deliver
so i think there's been a couple of
points on the table and clarification is
councillor boyce said
about uh whichever way becomes a
substantive motion could we perhaps say
goes back to a committee because
i think maybe we do need to have some
officer input because
if we go down the road as saying the
council offices and then we haven't got
the resources all the ways it's the
practicalities
i think there's a lot of principles here
but it's the practicalities german so
the amendment
i think is the one where people perhaps
see as being the most viable
at the moment uh what's being said
all right thank you and miss bird is it
possible to have the amendment up on the
screen please so that we can
you know uh yesterday
give me a second i can do that
okay so um
councillor stan did you want to come in
before councillor morris
if councillor morris wants to speak last
i don't mind
um thank you councillor morris
um excellent debates i totally agree
with the majority of what everybody
said um but and i certainly agree with
them councillor boyce
and chana uh and um the other members
about resources
can can we suggest a paper is brought
back to council at some stage
or a committee with the feasibility
which actually answers all members
questions chairman
because you can't design a policy or set
a policy
at a council meeting now it's just
impractical
impracticable or whatever they're saying
is chairman so i don't know if that
could be amended
depending on what council morris says
chairman but i think that's the way
forward
thank you chair for allowing me to speak
thank you leader um councillor morris
thank you very much um i'll try and get
us
through this as quick as i can i've not
just plucked this out of thin air and
brought it up to council
i have actually got quite a uh a history
in helping out vulnerable
and you know vulnerable people that need
food banks um everyone's saying that
there are other
smaller food banks going most of them
are food pantries they're not actually
proper food banks
the once road one and whilst i i must
stress
that i do not you know wanna i'm not i'm
not poor in school
on anything that anyone else has done
previously it's just quite simply
that they're inadequate what we've
currently got in this district
is inadequate once road is open for i
think three or four hours once a week
there is no parking the access isn't too
brilliant
um i was told that full bridge do food
parcels you can't even get a phone
number for them
um we've got um the cvs so
i spent some time on the phone today
finding out what they could do
as a you know as someone that might need
a food parcel
cvs didn't have a clue they put me onto
the trestle truck trust
which are the pinnacle of food bank
um charities that are here now the trust
will trust if you go on their website
they'll send you to chelmsford
to get a food bank malden needs a food
bank that
is accessible visible and reliable
we have got these smaller pantries
that are doing their best and i take
nothing away from them whatsoever
but we've got a massive problem here um
we've got over 60 000
residents and if you work on sort of
like the national
um figures 10 of those at
minimum will be um in poverty that's 6
000 people
and for the amount of hours we've got 6
000 people in the district that are in
poverty
that are going to tiny little pantries
that are open for
a few hours a week for one day a week we
simply need to open something that is
accessible
that is visible and that is reliable and
that
i believe should be in the council
offices
now i thank um councillor um
durham for supporting me and i hope that
more of you listen to him
um i'd like to say that um
councillor mays has said about
identifying the food banks
nobody can find the food banks a
counselor may spoke to me
about where where what other food banks
were in malden
and i was the one that had to point out
whether there was a pantry at
um once road we simply aren't providing
our our vulnerable residents with enough
we need to take this like a ball by the
homes
and we need to help our vulnerable
residents there's no
question that we haven't got the money
as we was put as this was pointed out to
us
by the conservatives at the budget
meeting we can dip into our reserves
there are grants from essex county
council
and everywhere we need to find solutions
not come up with problems okay we should
put a food bank into malden district
council offices
as quickly as we can and we should all
get on board
there are not enough councillors doing
enough work
for the vulnerable residents in the
district
and i regardless of what everyone says
here because i will be requesting a
recorded vote for this
the residents will be judging us on
whether or not we are prepared to help
the vulnerable people whilst we are
wasting our time and dragging our feet
there are people that need help that
will be starving
okay i think you think you've made your
point
uh councilman said i'm afraid i'll shut
my mouth because i'll get myself in
trouble oh can i just make one last
point please
um councillor boyce was going on about
horses and camels
well you know it just reminded me he's
talking about horses and camels
i thought i'd just mention that you're
not supposed to talk to um dogs about
bones
you're not supposed to talk to rats
about cheese and i would not like to
speak
to snakes about kindness okay
[Music]
this has been well uh well debated
um so uh tara could we just have the
amendment up on the screen again please
uh yes chairman no problem um just
advised councillors miss white
councilman cancer staff have got hands
up
right i'll take councillor white because
the others have
have already spoken um thank you
mr chairman for indulging me i mean i i
just wanted to say that although
i love the idea of it in principle we do
have a lot of other
food banks but i do think we also need
to
take heed of what the leader suggested
in
actually seeing how much this is going
to cost
not just notionally but also actual
costs and also whether as somebody else
mentioned whether we can actually get
the food into these banks because there
are a lot of other food banks so
yes it's a lovely idea but i don't think
that it should be decided tonight i
think it should come back with a full
feasibility study
thank you for letting me speak thank you
very much now
councillor maze it is your motion so you
are
um you are entitled to come back finally
[Music]
thank you mr chairman um i take a bit of
offense at
some of what has been said and um tabled
at some members here
i know that there are um members across
both parties all parties
who do an awful lot with regard to
homeless people
people in need people who have to use
food banks
and all of those things and i do take
offense of that
um and actually i feel very angry about
what was said because it's a very
unfair thing to say i have worked
tirelessly
over christmas and the new year and
um the the this amendment that was made
was done
for the benefit of the of the district
of the people that actually need the
service
and i actually would like to make a
further amendment
to the original amendment and that is to
look at getting the trussell trust
involved
which as um another member pointed out
is the pinnacle
of food bank operators and they don't
just
look at the um the food that has to that
that is needed on the streets but also
the
the supporting services the anything
that is provided by
cab if home start is needed
if gps are needed on site it will look
that
that that that organization has
such a good reputation nationally
and i would like to make the amendment
that the trussell trust
is brought in to look at how we can
develop
the services that we have across the
district
thank you mr chairman do i have a sector
for my um
second um uh amendment the amendment to
the amendment
outside sorry thompson yes
lots of us thank you very much mr uh
councillor helm and councillor thompson
i appreciate your support
thank you okay so if there is any
further debate
um it has to be um on the amendment uh
are we able to
um get some wording for that please miss
bird
uh yes chairman i can and can i just ask
councilman just to confirm the wording
again that she wants to be added please
thank you
uh yes thank you tara um i
think it needs to go in probably uh
where it says this support may include
offering assistance by our website
publicity as well as promoting a
multi-agency approach community needs
and the involvement of the crustal trust
in discussions to improve
the services district-wide
chairman chairman can we tag on to that
that a report comes back to council
please
a report needs to come back to council
no disrespect to amendments to
amendments to emotion
this council has to make that decision
and we can't make decisions without
having all the information chairman
so mays will allow that the report
and feasibility what council of white
councillor channel council boys and
everybody said
um i i think that is the best way
forward
thank you chairman thank you i i would
have come back to you councillor
stamp because uh obviously with another
amendment you can speak
only on the amendment uh councillor
thompson is this on the amendment
sorry so sorry chairman i'm beginning to
wonder what i'm doing with these buttons
um sorry i think council to the maze had
a brilliant idea which is why i stuck my
hand up but
ultimately this you know we we can't
design a system right now
here in this virtual chamber um
i think getting the trussel trust
involved is a fantastic idea
but can we you know obviously it's got
to come back as a report to council so
can we get officers to talk
to the trussle trust and bring us a
report back so we don't go through the
whole rigmarole twice
okay well what we'll do is we need to
know exactly what resources the council
could provide
and we need advice on the best way to
use it and that sounds to me like our
office is talking to the trestle
trust i don't know
those would be just get the words up and
then i think we'll go to the vote
chairman
i'm sorry i can't see who that is
chairman
yes councillor morris yeah can i ask for
a recorded vote on this one please
and um could you indulge me for 30
seconds please
yes you can talk on the amendment yes
yeah i'm fully in support of having the
trustal trust in
but i would like to remind members that
if they go to the trussel trust website
right now and tap in malden
food bank they will get sent to
chelmsford
what i am trying to say is that we have
something that is central to malden
and is available and accessible to the
whole district
it will benefit the whole district okay
we're just talking on the amendment at
the moment uh
i'm only taking questions on that leader
um chairman we are we have listened to
councillor morris and the amendment will
include the report coming back the
officers
will put a full and comprehensive report
through so can i reassure councillor
morris that
even if it goes to chelmsford the
officers won't just go
oh it's gone to chelmsford i'm not going
to do anything chairman and councilor
morris
the officers will provide a balanced
report back to this council to
councillor morrison
i'm saying that if you if if a resident
from
the district goes to the trussel trust
and taps in malden food bank the closest
one
is chelmsford so you know i'm not saying
it's going to chunks at offices or
anything like that i'm saying that
as far as the trust of trust is
concerned we have no food bank
and as councilor mays earlier stated and
as i've confirmed
the trust will trust other people that
we need to get involved in this
we need something that is accessible
that is visible and is reliable
currently we've got little
um little pantries that are not
coping okay um miss bed are we able to
get that wording up
now please
sorry i realize you're probably typing
away furiously at the moment
mr chairman yes councillor mays
um i i think i have to actually uh
include
um a slight amendment to my amendment
um to include the report from officers
okay i think we're just uh typing that
in
only a pledge to get one started so that
we could actually
get stop getting our teeth into it i'm
not against officers being involved in
it or anything
it's merely a pledge that we actually do
something rather than drag our feet
okay that's fine so we have
members you should be able to see the
proposed amendment
um which
i think do i have a seconder for that uh
for that that further amendment uh
secondary
schemes council schemes thank you very
much indeed
um so the amendment is okay
not enlarged it's very small print
okay so review of the current
difficulties our community faces morton
district council pledges to continue
working with outside agencies
to identify and support our existing
food banks
whilst investigating whether more food
banks are needed within the district
this support may include offering
assistance by a website publicity
as well as promoting a multi-agency
approach
to community needs and the involvement
of the trussell trust in discussions
to improve the services district-wide
and that a report be brought back to the
council
to provide further details so that has
been
proposed and duly seconded and uh
tara can you take the vote please for
this proposal
i cannot see the amendment chairman the
amendment hasn't come up is all i've got
is a picture of miss bird it's just
being led out to you mate
[Music]
a question for clarity please
yes if it is but i want to move to the
vote on this but go ahead
i just wondered if you could clarify
when the next
uh meeting of full council is because
listening to councillor morris this is a
very urgent
uh situation that we're dealing with
here so could you please clarify when
next four council lives thank you
thank you councilman we've got one in
four children in this district is in
poverty and you're trying to tell me we
need to identify
that that they need help one in four
children in this
13th
the chairman with respect i think the
proposal is may the 20th
that's a separate report chairman could
we have an emergency council well you
know an extraordinary council if
need be you know as soon as the
information is available could i ask
that we
actually meet thank you yes
okay i'm going to go to i'm going to go
to the vote now tara could you
generally just have a point of
clarification i'm not going to take any
more i'm sorry i'm going to go to the
vote on this
classification on the amendment we have
had a request
for a recorded vote is that seconded
yes it's second yes i'll celebrate okay
can you take
both these for or against this amendment
thank you chairman so members likes to
vote as per the amendment that was put
up on the screen
um if you could just indicate for
against rob statement i call your name
starting with councillor bassinger
please
thank you councilman four
thank you councillor brian bill
it won't come up
did you get that four please four thank
you councillor bill
casabelle four
cancer boys four thank you cancer mrs
channel
thank you cancer doran
i couldn't support the first amendment
but i will support this
if we can get things moving quickly
thank you so far
thank you very much councillor edwards
councillor mrs fleming
thank you council fluker
[Music]
four thank you councillor keys
four thank you cancer legend four
that's the maze four
thank you councillor morley oh sorry
he's not president counselor morris
too little too late feeling very
ambushed
against thank you cancer none
as long as we can move forward quickly
for
he cancer seances
speed is of the essence four
stamp four cancel stilts
four
paul this is thompson
four council miss white
four thank you chairman that's 25 4
1 against and no abstentions thank you
very much
thank you very much uh i declare that um
as agreed then
um thank you council morris for bringing
this matter to the attention of the
council
and i do hope that we can
see what you did tonight guys bye
right agenda item number 11
is questions in accordance with
procedure rules 6-3
which notice has been given and i can
buy i
can advise that we have not received any
questions
in accordance with this rule i'll move
on now
to agenda item number 12.
and this is the corporate plan update
update
this is found on pages 41
to 68. in a moment i'll call on the
leader
to present this item so members a
reminder that if you wish to speak on
this item
please make this known by using the
hands up function
uh in the meeting and then i'll come to
you in turn please
make your points clear and succinct
leader please introduce the report
thank you mr chairman yep the purpose of
the report it's quite clear
is to seek approval for an update on the
modern district council corporate plan
um i'm sure you've already and
highlighted some of the excellent work
that we're actually building on from the
previous culprit plan
uh it has been reduced in in the number
of i think it was 31 or something that's
been reduced down
but i think it's absolutely excellent
members i'm sure you've read the whole
report
and of the corporate plan and the
strategies and things that's going to
change within it or slightly be amended
i'm going to actually hand over to mr
dodson in a minute but before i do that
i'm actually going to put the
recommendation mr chair
and the recommendation is that members
consider and approve the modern district
corporate plan
2021-23 as set out in appendix one
do i have a seconder for my proposal
please mr church
thank you mr chair can i hand over to mr
dodson please
and he can give members a little bit
more uh
update on there if they've not had a
chance to read through it in great
detail
mr dodson
thank you leader thank you chairman um
good evening members
um further to the leaders introduction
of the plan
i wanted to also highlight that this is
an update of the current
2019-23 plan distilling some of the
outcomes
providing focus and reflecting the
changes we've seen over the last two
years
the corporate plan is a document and
statement of intent
that needs to be owned by the whole
organization and delivered through a
constructive working relationship
between council members and officers of
the council
so i'm very pleased that this updated
plan includes the statement of core
shared values
which i think is a really important
addition and we'll be able to embed
those values with both members and staff
the plan has been kept simple and to the
point
and i think it gives a clear focus for
the next two years
drawing our emphasis on economic growth
and recovery
community health and well-being and to
focus on the environment in our place
outcomes
the plan also maintains the focus on the
importance of performance and value
delivering effectively and using
resources efficiently
thank you chairman thank you very much
so we've had the recommendation that has
been duly seconded so we can now
discuss that and i'll now invite members
to make
any um comments sorry has anyone
indicated that they wish to speak
please and yes chairman councillor
flicker has his hand up thank you
thank you councillor fluker thank you
chairman um i think mr dodson's taking
my words when he said simple to the
point and i think that whoever put this
together whilst they've brought together
some very very important new issues that
they've identified
it is incredibly simple to the point and
i i would urge all members
to to support this recommendation and
the leader thank you
thank you council fluker um any other
speakers at all
uh miss bird uh chairman council mrs
china please thank you
thank you council mrs channel um
uh thank you well councillor queen has
said it in a way
and i just want to say i'm i'm glad it
is a an um
an update and not a total rewriting at
this stage because i think that's very
sensible
and i can see it's been very well
thought out and also
uh the members engagement and i do
notice of course there's been other
involvement with the staff
and businesses i think it was businesses
i'm trying to remember the surveys that
were done
in 2020 so i think it's been a good
fielding and collection
of views and to know that there is if
you like
um the staff and other sort of outside
bodies for one of a better word
involved in this and as well with the
members and from what i've um you know
read in the whole lodge although you
can't remember it all
just through one reading i think it does
capture actually the essence
of you know what the council feels and i
do agree with the shared values coming
in
um very much so because i think apart
from in the constitution where we might
have things
and elsewhere i think it doesn't hurt to
have a reminder
of the culture that needs to be within
the authority and have those shared
values and i think having it there
because officers will look at it regular
as will members i think it it really
drums those
the essences of um you know those those
benefits of
the values we should operate by reminds
us every day when we're looking at it so
thank you chairman
thank you councillor tanner are there
any other speakers at all please
tara no chairman nobody else thank you
thank you very much
in that case i will move to the vote our
members happy to agree
uh this piece of work by ascent agreed
thank you very much indeed thank you
we'll move on now to agenda item 13
this is the wiccan bishop's neighborhood
plan
decision on examiner's report this is
found on pages 69
to 130. again i will call on the leader
to present this item
and once again if you wish to speak use
the hands up function
and then i will come to you uh please
keep your points clear and succinct
uh leader please present the report
thank you mr chairman i'm more than
happy to report
uh to present this report to council
it's the wickham bishop
neighborhood plan decision on examiner's
report
it's to inform members and seek their
approval for the recommendations made in
the examiner's report appendix 1
on the wickham bishops neighborhood plan
and to seek member approval for the
neighbour plan to proceed to referendum
and chairman i'll read each
recommendation out in turn if that's
okay little one is the term little three
is that okay chair
yes that's fine thank you leader right
the examiner's modification be agreed
and that's subject to these
modifications the neighborhood plan
meets the basic conditions
and other legislative requirements
little two
that the draft decision statements
attached as appendix to
be to be approved uh sorry members be
approved to be published on the
council's website
and little three that the and bishop's
neighborhood plan be agreed
as modified and proceeds to a local
referendum
based on the boundary of wiccan bishops
neighborhood area
as recommended by the examiner i'd like
to propose that members and can i have a
second please
councillor mays thank you chair
councillor maze thank you very much okay
so we can
now further discuss this should i invite
sorry sorry chairman
i was quick to shut off my microphone do
apologize should i hand this now to mr
dodson to give members
a little bit of update on this before
cancer channel comes in because i see
that she's got her hand up
yes that's fine thank you mr johnson
thank you chairman um not a great deal
to add to be honest i mean the report
informs members
of and seeks their approval for the
recommendations made in the examiner's
report on the wiccan bishops
neighborhood plan and seeks
members approval for the neighbourhood
plan to proceed to referendum
the report does set out the purpose of
the neighborhood plan
and the role of molden district council
as the local planning authority
and having considered each of the
recommendations made in the examiner's
report
and the reasons for them officers
believe that the examiner has undertaken
a fair and robust examination of the
submitted neighborhood plan
and recommended the council accept all
of the examiners modifications to the
draft plan
wiccan bishops neighborhoods planned
steering group has advised that it has
agreed with the modifications
recommended and the parish council voted
to accept the examiner's amendments on
the 2nd of march
this year subject to the council's
approval
the plan can then move to referendum and
this would take place alongside the
elections on the 6th of may
thank you chairman
thank you very much mr dodson i believe
we have uh two speakers
uh councillor channer and councillor
jarvis so councillor chana first please
um thank you very much chairman well i
wholeheartedly um
support the recommendation and i'd just
like to say i'm
and i know this and i know councillor
stamp will or the leader will
uh because burnham have got one and i
i'm aware of other areas and
i i applaud actually parish councils
that go through this process and do this
working with the communities
um coming together all the community
doing it and working with the parish
because it does take a lot of time and
effort however i do
think it is worth it in the long run
because they've been through the
examination
um should this all be agreed tonight
they can have the referendum and a
neighborhood plan
is a material consideration in the
planning process
so i uh applaud what uh wiccan bishops
has done
um and the work they've applied to this
and you know the fact they've accepted
the modifications that really shows that
we really should support this
recommendation chairman thank you
thank you council channel councillor
jarvis thank you chairman um
just before i make a comment i should i
should i think disclose i am a
as a pecuniary interest uh non-bikini
interest i am of course a wiccan bishops
parish councillor
so if that could just be recorded i'm
sorry if i didn't do that at the
beginning of the meeting
but i'd just like to say uh having said
that that uh
you know yes you know i mean it's it's
an excellent report they've taken
everything on board a huge amount of
work has gone into producing the
document
as it as they do for all parishes um i
think the recommendations are good and
they've taken on board
obviously the comments of the
professional advisors and
i'd like wholeheartedly to recommend uh
if i may
uh to to the council um the uh the
report before you
thank you thank you councillor jarvis
um tara are there any other people
wishing to speak
please um oh yes i've got cancer durham
uh councillor swain wanting to speak
thank you
thank you councillor durham yeah thank
you very much chairman i'd like to
congratulate wicking bishops parish
council
on on getting over the line thus far
um they were in they were in a bit of a
race with uh
um ulti and langford on their
neighbourhood plan but uh
wickham bishop seemed to have had the uh
the rub of the green let's call it that
um and their
their hard work and dedication has
pulled off i sincerely hope it goes
through
i sincerely hope that the value of a
neighborhood plan doesn't get diluted
with the proposed
planning white paper but there's nothing
we can do about that
but no i i wholeheartedly support it so
well done thank you
thank you councillor durham councillor
swain
and yes thank you chairman i'm concerned
about the timing of a referendum
um if it's to be when the local
elections are
um then i feel be a very low turnout and
it needs 50 percent
to um to be approved i think some
considerations should be given to when
you can
to giving time to people to and and the
opportunity to
carry out a um what you say a more
fruitful referendum
a bit later than may
thank you for that mr johnson did you
want to come back on anything
at all
yes thank you chairman i i understand
there's a time limit
on when this has to be um go to
referendum
um following approval um here
and i think that's 56 days
so that that would actually be an
earlier
um referendum under normal circumstances
and it will be delayed
because of the um current restrictions
on elections may the sixth being the
first date that it could happen
thank you thank you any other speakers
at
all please tara that the chairman can i
can i just add then
if the if there is a strict time limit
um and one wants to ensure greater
participation is there a case for
actually postponing formal approval
are you able to answer that mr dodson
i thank you yes chairman i don't believe
that's in our gift
i'm sorry i can't quite can't quite here
i don't believe that is that better
yeah thank you okay i don't believe that
that's in our gift
to delay it um that there's a statutory
process that's that's set out
is in front of us now to approve and um
it needs to be we need to make a
decision on it so that it can then
continue through the statutory process
thank you um i've right okay i think
that hand has been uh extinguished now
uh any other speakers
at all at least tara uh chairman
councillor stamps got a hand up please
thank you
i'm sorry i can't see that uh and cancer
stamp leader chairman can i ask um
mr lee i know it's a different officer
who normally knows about um the
neighborhood plan and forgive me i
should know because
like what counselor china said we we've
gone through it at burnham
but it's it's the number of people who
vote
percentage-wise who agree with it not
the number of votes isn't it
unless i've totally lost my mind because
i think it can be
i can remember in burnham i'm sure it's
only 29 or 33 percent turned out but it
was a number of people
who supported it sorry mr lee i've
jumped a jump turn on your
thunder there but i just thought it'd be
better if you could confirm that to
assure reassure the members
are you able to respond mr lee it i know
there is a
percentage about the vote to be honest i
can i'm exactly in the process of trying
to double check it
and i'll give you memphis who wish to
leave that with me i can double check
that online i don't want to give
anything off
the cuff that's incorrect but mr dodson
raised his hands too much you have the
answer himself
yeah mr dawson it's included in the
report
yes exactly is included in the report on
page 74
0.7.7 following referendum if more than
50 percent of
those voting vote yes then the
neighborhood plan must be made within
eight weeks of the referendum
so so that answers it that it is um 50
of those voting not 50 of the electorate
that's good thank you very much uh any
other any further questions tara
no chairman that's everyone i believe
thank you thank you very much
in that case uh i will now um go to the
vote
uh there seems uh general support for
this are we able to agree that by ascent
please
agreed agreed
i couldn't quite count 31 but i think
that was all agreed thank you
we next move to agenda item 14
which is future committee meetings
options
again i will refer to the leader
to present this item the game members if
you wish to speak
please be clear and succinct leader
please
introduce the report thank you
mr chair um i don't know if you will
allow me to ask mr dodson if there's
been any if there has been any
um legal update um from when the report
was written
from central government has anything
changed before i
present this report mr chairman am i
allowed to ask that please
thank you yes mr dodson yeah i think for
a point of clarity i think we should
know that if there is
thank you chairman um i can confirm
there's been no change
and um as things currently stand on the
6th of may the legislation
um will end allowing us to operate um
remote meetings thank you mr dodson and
thank you chairman
so obviously the purpose of the report
is to update the members
of the approach of options for council
and committee meetings from the 6th of
may 2021
when the current current remote meeting
legislation expires
and the recommendations mr chair are
litter one
that members review the details set out
in this report
and are assured that officers are doing
all they can to scope future options
with the limited information provided
and little two that final decision of
the future approach to meetings be
delegated to the director of strategy
performance and governance in
consultation
with the leader um i'd like to make that
as a proposal
and will somebody second my proposal
please
councillor mays that's amazing
i'm now going to hand over to mr dodson
who's
put the report together members have
actually had all the
the risk assessment all the options uh i
think
mr dodson and his team have looked into
this at great length
and i know it's a very difficult
situation um chairman
and we all are hoping that central
government will allow some sort of
hybrid meetings
before and i want to reassure members
that if things
do change it will change straight away
mr dodson and the team
directors have assured me that if it
changed
this will not stay as it is those
decisions
could and council could carry on meeting
whether it be a hybrid type meeting i'm
going to hand over to mr dodson because
i've spoken a bit too much
chair thank you thank you mr dodson
thank you chairman um as the leader said
as things currently stand on the 6th of
may the legislation allowing for remote
meetings will cease
in the short term if these powers are
lost after the 6th of may
we'll be in the impossible position of
not being able to hold meetings remotely
but also having to restrict the number
of councillors that attend
meetings to adhere to social distancing
requirements
we and many other local government
colleagues have conveyed our
disappointment in this to central
government
and there's an ongoing high court
challenge that seeks to ensure the
online remote meetings can continue
but as of now we're having to review
alternative options for committee
meetings
with unvaccinated staff and members and
expectations around social distance in
space
there are many risks and costs involved
in physical meetings
as set out in appendix one
as of today we don't currently have a
space that could host all 31 members for
a socially distanced physical meeting
and also meet the other requirements
that we need to do in terms of i.t
um etc or all of the the
the sound recording etc
as the landscape and guidance is
continuously changing
this report outlines the current work
and further details on the options
and requests that a final decision is
delegated to me as director of strategy
performance and government
governance in consultation with the
leader
in seeking that delegation i want to
assure members that we will do our
utmost to ensure we're able to continue
with meetings
online or physical meetings but that
whatever solution we reach
will be in keeping with the social
distance guidelines and will prioritize
the safety of officers members and the
public
and i firmly believe the best option
would be the extension of the current
legislation to enable online meetings
until such time as we can reconvene
safely in the council chamber
thank you
thank you very much um right i think
i've got um
i can see some hands but i can't see who
they are tara could you tell me
who uh who wishes to speak please um yes
of course chairman
uh councillor lagan council fluker
councilman mrs thompson
council mrs fleming councillor swain
councillor miss white
thank you chairman i think i did manage
to get all of those
thank you so uh so the motion has been
proposed and seconded so we can discuss
it further
i'll go first to councillor lagan yeah
thank you chair um
this is a really difficult situation
isn't it it's like trying to pre-get
something
that will have to change otherwise
central government stops local
government stops
government stops at each level because
we we find ourselves in an impossible
position where nobody can meet
in any forum therefore my my belief is
that
the the government will make an
amendment to the legislation
and at that point uh give us some
clarity and the logical solution has to
be a hybrid
hybrid solution however having said that
there's some concerns that i had um for
consistency
i was vehemently against the previous uh
um
process where the leader and the
officers uh
were making the decisions um and
excluding members
therefore excluding the views of other
people within the areas
and that's from every political
persuasion or those of us that are
non-political
uh it limits the representation although
i i do
understand things have changed in that
in that type of space
um i i firmly believe the recommendation
to
little one is is absolutely true
and sound i think that the officers are
doing all they can
with regard to looking at the options
but i'm concerned when i looked at the
risk
assessment for the recommendations
there's no detail of how those decisions
are made
they're made on assumptions there are
buildings that are available
and i have a bit of disappointment that
we haven't been on the case earlier on
looking at hang on if this stopped
what would it take for us to meet social
distancing because there is a one meter
plus mitigation rule in place which
means
you don't need as much space as what
people think we're talking about static
social distancing not dynamic social
distancing which is a whole different
kind of fish
the hens face space message can work and
people can be and engage with each other
in safety
so from that perspective i disagree
and i regrettably i don't feel i can
support the recommendation
and to to hand over and i firmly feel we
should look at
off-site meetings uh and even the
chamber with regard to sizing
and social distancing and come back with
an actual detailed summary
because others do it it can be done i've
been working in a business that
has kept safe since day one of this
awful pandemic
and it's just a view that i have so i
think we can be done we need to show the
residents we can do it
it will be scary let's let's let's
debates no odds it will be challenging
but we can do it and we should do it so
i'm vehemently against the handing over
as we did in the past thank you members
thank you
thank you um councillor councillor
fluker
thank you german um i think at a
previous meeting i may have misheard
something that councillor lagan said so
i i apologize for that
but i don't think i missed her what he
said tonight so i think just for clarity
when we went into emergency powers
before um it actually included a leader
of the opposition as well
but german i i am like councillor lagan
you know concerned about this i mean the
government has led has left us in a very
difficult position
um the prime minister has said uh this
evening
that there will be no easing until the
12th of april
now that that leaves a lot of time
between now and the 12th of april
later on this evening i think we'll be
deciding whether or not to hold the
status january meeting on the 20th of
may
that is a very big gap so chairman
through you my question is actually to
the leader
um to ask a leader that when we actually
know something whether or not she will
be
prepared with your support chairman to
call an extraordinary meeting the
council so we can agree what we're going
to do
particularly bearing in mind that the
statutory annual
meeting is very close thank you chairman
i suppose i'm making a proposal really i
don't know if i'm going to make it but
i'm rather hoping the leader is going to
make it
so uh as the leader said earlier i'll
shut up now thank you
sorry chairman sorry do you want me to
to answer that i think councillor fluker
knows
that she the leader will call an
extraordinary meeting
uh if if it changes it goes without
saying
and and council fluker i'm sure you
would have done the same previously when
you was the leader
it's it's for the benefit of our
residents and the councillors and yes
rest assured
that as soon as things change i tried to
allude to that when i did the speech at
the beginning mr chairman
if things change the officers are well
aware the officers have worked so hard
there's been letters going to government
to ministers for the district council's
network council fluke
knows all this when he was the leader
there's a bigger network
and they've all tried to facilitate to
get the government to listen to us
so yes of course councillor fluke and
you can please make
make the amendment yourself well
chairman if you allow me to come back
i i'll make the proposal now and i'll
i'll call for a second
and i'm i'm sure chairman that the the
the leader will will second that because
i
i think we do need to have this debate
and and it may appease councillor most
because we could have food banks
agenda as well i think council helm my
second there
i'll second that thompson he hasn't made
it yet
germany hasn't made it yet
what amendment please chair and council
what is the uh proposal council
i think it's going to almost have to be
as woolly as the government's advice on
all of this insofar as the fact that
chairman
uh at the discretion of the uh not at
the discussion but at the request of the
leader and at the discretion of the
chairman
that once we have some more information
we will call
an extraordinary meeting of this council
to consider
what is best for the council thank you
i'm sure that uh well as the leader has
intimated that that
will uh that will take place um so i i
have noted that i have noted it's been
seconded
uh i will just take uh the other
speakers first councillor thompson
thank you i think i might have been
overtaken by events chairman but i was
going to ask that should we end up with
recommendation little too
uh could as the um as council of lucas
suggested could the leader of the
opposition be included because that's
not
far off half the council and it was what
we did on the decisions
to you know when we went into this awful
situation
thank you thank you councillor fleming
thank you chair my gut feeling is that
uh
something will be done by central
government and something will go forward
but uh just in case that doesn't happen
um i personally would like to go back to
the chamber
i voted against emergency powers last
march
i think there's an important democratic
principle at stake
so without an amendment to little to
um i won't be able to support that thank
you
thank you councillor swain
yes thank you um chairman yes the one or
two
points really and some of them to be
born in mind
by the uh the directors perhaps when
i think it's trying to sort out a way
forward but the crucial thing is missing
is we don't seem to have any idea
but what is the um the number that the
chamber could accommodate and i wonder
whether a serious
um analysis has been undertaken of what
the chamber could accommodate because if
it can accommodate say
10 councillors then most of the
committees
could function in the chamber and when
it comes to something like a district
planning committee that could be
composed of
a number from each of the the area
groups
um i also wonder um
whether they could look at the
possibility that
the mem though not officially in
existence
for the purposes of coming to um what
you say
acceptable decisions whether um
virtual groups of the members of the
individual committees
could take place um in a sort of
advisory capacity
uh for before the directors make any
decisions of importance
um i agree with that point that it
probably ought to be more than
just the leader um and perhaps it should
be
you know three or four people uh should
be consulted
um if we do have to go to that um
extreme situation
the other as far as council is concerned
um we could look at somewhere
for an occasional it would only be
council itself which would need to meet
as 30 people
um as i say the others could be the
district planning could be condensed
and if the chamber can accommodate say
10 people
then most of the committees could
function properly
the other element that has been left
entirely out of consideration
is the public um participation and
involvement by the public is obviously
much
greater with the virtual meetings and
the more we um shrink down to
delegated powers and so on the less the
public
know what is going on and i think that's
an important thing that's
being lost and we need to bear that in
mind just one element when
one considers um restricting
member activity thank you thank you
thank you very much
councillor swain the only thing i would
say is i know that the other committees
i think there's 15 on one 16 on another
so i don't think that uh i'm not really
sure
whether mr dodson would be able to
assist further on that
at 10 or 11.
thank you chairman yes they are 10 and
11 um
now under the the changes um that were
made
but we're doing further work looking at
the
the chamber but there are fundamental
issues with the the accessibility the
closeness
of the the um horseshoes to each other
in the first case place the positioning
of
officers and members on the top table if
that's
what's required and the access in and
out
excuse me um so you know
work will continue and we're continuing
to look at
all options and to to work up more
risk assessments and and to try and work
out what opportunities there are
um
sorry i was going to make another point
there but it's it's completely slipped
my mind
so i think you've answered the answer
the question um
anyway i'll just go uh now to
um councillor white
uh thank you mr chairman for allowing me
to speak um all i would say is
i'm i fall into the clinically
vulnerable
group sadly just my health and
what i would say is it it's all very
well talking about physical meetings
but please spare a thought for those of
us who
would be unable to attend certainly in
the short term
and much as i miss the physical meetings
you know we need to bear in mind that
i'm not going to be the only person who
cannot attend any public meetings at all
i mean since march last year i haven't
been to the hairdresser's
actually since last christmas i've been
the hairdressers i yeah
i haven't i think i've been to a
supermarket on three occasions i think
i've been to a garden center once you
know and some of us have really had to
stick
by this so please spare a thought for
those of us
rather than trying to rush through the
physical meetings let's wait until the
data catches up and it's absolutely safe
you know
we need to keep safe we need to show
lead by example
not just rush into physical meetings and
i say i really miss the physical
meetings i absolutely miss them
it's not the same doing it remotely you
don't feel so involved
but you know it's a good effort so let's
let's thank the officers for what
they've done
and i support the motion to wait and see
what guidance comes forward in the
future
thank you thank you very much um anybody
who hasn't
uh spoken before tom yes please
i've got so if i could just come back
because it's really relevant to
councillor white's point that she just
made
um as someone who is also clinically
extremely vulnerable i was overjoyed
today to receive a letter from matt
hancock
saying that i can go out again into the
community from the first of april
so i don't know if that's helpful uh
members and officers to know
that uh shielders can now see shielding
from the first of april
thank you thank you tara any other
speakers
please yes councillor darren transfer
mrs channel
councillor helm cancer stamp casserole
council fleming councillor none
thank you okay um i'm going to
uh take those people who haven't spoken
on this
uh yet councillor durham thank you
chairman chairman i
you know we're going to have to be a
little bit realistic and and um
the reason that that government haven't
come out with anything
is that it's it's not a point that it's
not something they don't want to do it's
a point of constitutional law
they're unable by law to make an
amendment
to the coronavirus act 2020
and to take it any further is we're
going to require
primary legislation the minister lou
call has gone to
the leader of the house jacob rees-mogg
and we all know what he's like for
constitutional law
and and he has said you can forget it
mate because there just isn't any
parliamentary time
so it's not from a lack of of of wanting
um as i said it's a legal point and the
leader is absolutely right
every organization under the sun
representing
local government has been petitioning
saying what on earth are you going to do
because after the the 6th of may there
is still
until the 21st of june at the earliest
uh the restrictions in place now in
terms of what we do essex county council
have actually been
forward thinking because it is every
councillor's right
to appear at full council meetings
um so you can't have a a hybrid full
council meeting
so uh the the chamber essex county
council anybody that knows that which
normally will seat
75 members and with officers there's
over 100 people attending
to maintain social distancing its
capacity is only 45.
so about two months ago the the search
went on for alternative
uh locations for its full council and
the cathedral and
other large venues have been put forward
so
i think we need to start doing that very
thing
now and identifying a room
that we can use and maintain social
distancing until such time as social
distancing
is no longer required in and we have to
accept the fact that as councilor white
has said
even when the the we are allowed to go
back to the chamber there may be some
people reticent to do so
um that's inevitable but that is their
choice they cannot be prevented from
going there
so chairman ins in conclusion we need to
get out
now to have our statutory annual meeting
and have every member present
and find a location that is suitable
thank you
thank you councillor channel
i think councillor durham is a mind
reader
because he's more or less said
everything i was going to and i'm a
essex county council as well
so obviously i'm aware of what county
council has been doing
i think there's the two elements here we
know we've got to continue the virtual
meetings right up until the 6th of may
and that's fine
and councillor lagan made points but
also um
councillor darwin's really put the facts
on the table
and i believe we should be looking at
that and actually councillor swain
you're also a mind reader
because my view is we look for the main
council meeting
to be outside in an outside venue i can
think of somewhere where you could have
very good social distancing and all 31
members could get in there
and then the committees could be in the
council chamber
and i've read the report and it says how
much that would cost really just with
the perspective and the sanitizer
the committees i do think there's a way
the chamber could be used and that could
be the back seats as well
i mean we'd have to recognize there
might be a bit of changing needed to go
on
but i think we've we're being forced
into that route where we have got to
really start thinking about that because
nothing's going to change so we're left
there and i think we've got to start
lobbying
the mps i know we've lobbied the
government i know we've got the lga on
board
and other things but ca i think pretty
patel and john whittingdale could help
out here
but i i do believe um for the statutory
annual
the 31 members um because that time
they'll be that have they had the
by-elections
um i i think we do really need to look
at that route and i appreciate what the
leader is saying if there's any changes
um but we'll have to wait and see we've
still got a little while to go
and if we move the statutory annual to
the 20th of may which is on the agenda
later tonight
we've still got to play time to play
with councillor bell's absolutely
correct the shielders now
have been told they need no longer
shield so that's another change in the
equation
and i know what counselor durham said
but i really do think we've got to do
the work
and get doing it now and that's why we
i'm i have vulnerabilities myself
and you've all saw me on the in the
march meeting going with the with the
mask
on um i i won't have any problem doing
that if i'm required to do so but i
think the
democracy um calls for those being the
options and i'm afraid not the others
that are on the sheet the officers
i'm very grateful to officers what
they're looking at and it must be a
terrible thing for them having to work
this out and think and the best way
forward but i do think the public will
want to see us all back together
but of course it will be have to be done
safely and there's ways i think we can
do that
outside venue and also internal for
committees
in in our account services thank you
very much mr dobson did you want to come
back on any of that
mr dawson yes thank you sorry couldn't
find my
buttons um yes j i just wanted to
highlight that
similarly to county council officers and
we acted with foresight two
in um looking at venues and we have done
significant research looking at what
venues may be available
as yet we've not found anywhere that's
ideally suitable with the correct id um
web access um social distance in space
etc we continue on with that work and
you know as i said in my introduction we
will continue
throughout this process to look for the
ideal venues to ensure that we can do
that
but i would like to emphasize again a
couple of other things one
is that hybrid meetings aren't possible
in any context so
we haven't um forgotten public access
um but if we have public access to
face-to-face meetings that needs to be
face-to-face
as well and uh
secondly the um
we we will continue as i said looking at
all of those options make sure that
we've scoped out all of the venues
looked at those that are available
and done those risk assessments but we
will put the safety
of members staff
and the public at the centre of what we
do
thank you okay thank you very much um
councillor helm
thank you very much chairman um i was
listening quite intensely councillor
thompson who suggested the leader of the
opposition ought to be involved in
emergency powers i'll suggest the leader
of the
other group be included as well this
happens at clt meetings so it'd be quite
appropriate and quite widespread for all
of us to be involved thank you mr
chairman
thank you very much councillor lagan and
fleming have already spoken
on this uh i will come to leader finally
but councillor nunn you're next
thank you very much chair well um i very
much hope like
many of you do or probably all of us do
that the legislation
uh does change despite what councillor
durham has said i hope that the
government do
find a way around this and that remote
meetings can continue because i believe
that remote meetings have gone very well
and in fact
i think they've increased public
participation
uh in the democratic process and in our
meetings
certainly a lot more people seem to be
watching via
uh this setup or via youtube than
uh i used to see actually in the chamber
so i think it has gone well
we've got a bit of a way to go until the
6th of may
but i find myself agreeing with
councillor white
um i certainly don't want to physically
meet yet
um i haven't from a personal point of
view i haven't even had my first jab yet
so i don't want to to meet
but things could change by the 6th of
may because we're not just putting
ourselves
at risk as mr dobson said
we would be putting the officers at risk
potentially
and if they turn up members of the
general public
i think the report is good and i support
the recommendation but
i think there should be a proviso that
the moment there is any change
in the regulations that allow us to
continue with remote meetings
that these should be uh they they should
be the way that we go
until things are a lot easier thank you
very much
thank you i think we i think we have had
that uh proposal and it was duly
seconded by councillor maize
do we have any wording for that please
and tara
gentlemen you want to start can i come
back as a matter of clarity because i'm
i'm sure that
um um tara if she has got what i said
she's probably got a lot of goody goo
like i've got written in front of me so
chairman what i propose is that i would
draw
my proposal and i put the following one
chairman which i think is what
the leader was prepared to support
and that is chairman that leader of the
council in in con
in conjunction with the chairman calls
an extraordinary meeting to consider
options once further information is
forthcoming from the government
on the process of holding meetings after
the sixth of may
i think that covers everything off
chairman but you know i've reread what
prime minister said today
and he really isn't talking about easing
anything until
the earliest the 12th chairman thank you
thank you um so that's uh i'm not sure
if you were able to get that immediately
um tara but do i have a seconder for
that
councillor thompson thank you very much
uh so
uh leader did you i was gonna come back
to you finally
um yes thank you chair i'm afraid i'm
going to put my two penis in there's a
personal
level here um i certainly agree with
councillors wood um sorry
white and none um i missed my father's
funeral couldn't go to it because of
covid
i've got a sick mother with alzheimer's
i can't go and see her because of covid
and i'm very reticent to put my life at
risk to go to meetings
unless because nobody can assure you and
guarantee that
you will not catch covid i feel very
strongly about this i too haven't had
my jab and i would not
personally chairman and it is emotional
i would not ask
anybody to have to attend a face-to-face
meeting if they
feel vulnerable and and as the leader of
this
council we need to take that into
account
i am more than happy to extend
the uh little to to include um
councillors chana and helm and another
member if they want chairman
so so we can actually make sure that the
working and operation of this this
council continues
but i would be very very it would take
me a lot
to attend meetings chairman until it was
absolutely
safe we all have families we all have
that vulnerabilities and we can pass it
on you don't know if you're a super
spreader i don't know if i'm a super
spreader
i've stayed in like most of these
members have and we've had these remote
meetings
and i'm sorry i've got passionate
chairman it's a great deal to me this
and i think
the members have to seriously think
about
the recommendations on the table mr
chair
thank you for indulging me thank you
thank you very much uh i'm going to
we've still got quite a bit to go
through members so i'm going to
i'm going to go to the vote i think this
has been well uh
well debated record please chance
chairman chuck can i just ask mr dodson
a question
yes go ahead uh mr dodson which venues
have you actually been to look at
for a statutory annual
are you happy to help mr dodson
uh we've been looking at the town
council we're looking at the
the churches in the area we're looking
at the
community centers that are available
there's a whole list and we're still
doing that work as well
we've actually been to visit mr dodson
personally i haven't known but um
our um facilities frank frank has
basically been
um to do the work that the same person
who's doing
all of the risk assessments for all of
the 45 polling stations
that we need to to go through the same
process with um
for the election thank you
okay so we've got um the three
recommendations the two that are set out
beside you and also
a further one that if anything uh does
come to light
that we will uh recall we'll have an
emergency meeting leader
uh chairman can we sorry cancer china
can we make sure that the
recommendations are read out fully
because
i think i made a small amendment to
include councillors helm and chana
that needs to be clear sorry that's a
chance
oh yeah
again please tara are you able to do
that hey chairman i just i need council
for er
fluke just to re read this out i've got
most of it but not all of it the rest of
it i believe i've got you
okay could you are you able to read that
out at typing speed councillor fluka
chairman that the leader of the council
in conjunction with the chairman calls
an extraordinary meeting
to consider options once further
information is forthcoming from the
government
on the process of holding council
meetings after
the 6th of may is that typing speed
not my typing speed
did you manage to get that um tara um
almost just the last tiny bit please
cancel the freak if you don't mind
repeating that'd be lovely
not too fast thank you uh right okay so
consider options once
further information is fourth coming
from the government
on the process of holding council
meetings after the sixth of may
sorry chairman matt have clarification
on something
yes go ahead the leader um
just latterly has said she's happy to
include other
persons is that on little two i'm just
trying to be clear of the
the recommendations so she's saying on
little two
yes i'm just coming to that it should
include uh
the director of strategy performance and
governance in consultation with the
leader of the council
and the opposition uh two parties
should that include the chairman um yes
leader
yes and so those are the arrangements as
before
um well i don't know as bad as before
with that with that body then be looking
at the options as well that's what i'm
not quite clear on
that's a final decision on the future
approach
right so okay they would be involved in
looking at the options i think that's
important all members know that then
check chairman i don't think that's what
councillor fluka's
um amendment was no this was yours
you're an amendment leader
sorry okay i'm gonna say council of
lucas was that i would call the meeting
wasn't it
what we'll do is we'll get those we'll
get those up
yeah my point is chairman i don't really
want further debate on this because
we've got other work to get through
uh for this clarification what i'm
saying is i think the leader means
little too to add those
others to look at the further work and
then should
something i think counselor fluke is
adding on that should we get further
information from the government
then an extraordinary meeting would be
called so i think little two would be
looking at the way forward with those
persons the leaders proposed
and then should further um
uh sort of direction come from the
government the extraordinary meeting
will be called i think that's important
i think that's what the leaders meaning
i think they're up before us the the
three options
the three recommendations are up here
um chairman
uh yes councillor swain where does this
leave the list of um
options that were mentioned are we not
expressing any preference
um for final decision
the final this is in recommendation too
the final decision will be left
to the director of strategy performance
and governance in consultation
with the the leader the chairman leader
of the opposition parties
yeah and that's what and that's what
it's
that's what it's uh that's what it's
saying uh and we've also got
councillor fluka's uh proposal
uh about uh calling an extraordinary
meeting of the council
so i'm uh could ask you to put your
hands down now please and we'll go for
the vote please tara
okay chairman and chairman there was an
indication for recorded vote but i don't
believe that was seconded
okay uh i've uh i've had a request for a
recorded vote i'm trying to recall who
is strong is it cancer lagging
counsellor yeah okay is that second that
okay we'll uh we'll we'll go with the
recorded vote then please tara
thank you chairman thank you members so
um as opposed on the screen the three
recommendations
if you could just indicate four against
rostaine please
starting with councillor bassinger
please could we put them up on the
screen again please
yes let me just
thank you very much okay so starting
with cancer passenger please
against cancer miss bill
paul thank you cancer brian bill
or mrs channel
chairman leader thank you for uh um
putting forward
councillor helm and i and four i think
that's very good thank you
cancer durham
thank you very much councillor mrs
fleming
against um sorry you forgot me tara
apologies cancer edwards i do apologize
sorry four
thank you sorry about that uh councillor
fluker please poor thank you councillor
head
yes i'm for cancer health
or thank you councillor howe
paul jarvis
four that's the keys
four cancer lagging
against please tara raise
four morris
i think he's left the meeting okay
thank you council shauna c four
cancer four can key cancer schemes
four thank you stamp
sorry tyler at four thank you councillor
stilts
four cancer swain against
that's mrs thompson
sorry for i'm losing control of my
buttons
thank you very much uh councillor miss
white
oh please tara thank you thank you
chairman the results of that are 22
4 4 against and no abstentions thank you
chairman
thank you therefore that that is agreed
uh thank you for that thank you members
we move on now to agenda item 15 these
are appointment of representatives to
modern district
dementia alliance and the vacancy for
the investigating and disciplinary
committee
these are found on pages 141 141-146 and
in a moment i'll call on the leader to
present this item
members please use the hands up function
for this meeting if you wish to speak
please keep your points clear and
succinct
leader please introduce the report um
thank you chairman thank you members for
a really excellent debate on that
difficult subject so thank you very much
apart this
this report is to appoint the
representative to molden district
dementia rely
action alliance and vacant investigating
and disciplinary committee seat
so the purpose of report is to consider
the appointment of the representative to
serve on the modern district dementia
action alliance outside body and to
ratify the independent group nomination
for invest
investigating and disciplinary committee
the recommendations mr chairman members
are little one
that the appointment of the
representative to molden district
dementia reliance is as detailed in
appendix 1
be agreed for the remainder of the
municipal year and little 2
that the nomination from the independent
group that councillor
s p nunn be appointed to the
investigating and disciplinary committee
um by uh by be approved and i'd like to
put that proposal forward and can i have
a second to please obviously we'll have
to have a name
for little one german council
on the investigation and disciplinary
committee
uh are there any other guys
councilman
right councillor mays the nomination for
the representative for the dementia
alliance
thank you mr chairman um i would like to
nominate councillor wendy stamp
um as she has personal um experience of
this
uh and would make a very good
representative for the council going
forward thank you
thank you is that seconded counselor
none seconded
uh chairman could i just also say i was
going to propose counselor ann beale
because for similar reasons um
i understand that we've had a proposal
and it has been seconded if that fails
i'll come back to you councillor janna
uh the second
well i guess we can take the vote uh we
can take the vote on that now if you
wish
chairman chairman i know this is going
to be slightly
um what's the word not normal um
but i i actually can i withdraw can can
counselor maze withdraw hers because i
think counseling and beale would
make an excellent and it's for the
municipal year
um so could i request that councillor
mays withdraws it yes i would like to be
on this
but um i totally concede that council
beal um
could also be very good at it and i i'm
going to ask for that to happen thank
you
councillor mays are you prepared to uh
withdraw your second
uh yes uh yes i will mr mr chairman okay
do i have another proposal then
councillor
tanner um can i just say that's very
gracious of the leader to do that
um so yes i i stand by i was going to
say counselor ann beale
the good viewer
i did you get any of that term
counsellor none seconded
thank you very much uh so that is for
the uh
the the first recommendation uh i'll
i'll is that can that be agreed by a
cent
agreement agreed
please agree uh thank you for that
and uh thank you councillor bill do you
agree
do you agree to uh to be being that
representative
yes thank you i'll try and remember that
okay
thank you very much uh the second
recommendation
uh is that uh there's a nomination from
the independent group that council
and none be appointed to the
investigation and disciplinary committee
is that council amaze i second that
that has been seconded are we going to
agree that by a cent member yes
yes agreed
thank you uh are there any other
speakers who wish to speak on this
excuse me chairman uh councilman just
[Music]
okay so those have both been agreed um
a sent and we'll move on to
agenda item 16.
uh we any chance of a comfort break
channel
yes well said cancer well that's a good
idea
whatever whatever happens members this
meeting will will cease at nine o'clock
so uh i'm i'm happy to give you maybe no
comfort right
no seriously cancer thompson i second a
comfort break
thank thank you thank you mr chairman
and you're back live chairman thank you
thank you very much
well uh welcome back members
colleagues and uh members of the public
um we've had a short break uh and we're
now commencing
uh and i open this meeting again at uh
2020 we move on to
agenda item 16 which is establishing a
planning policy working group
uh in a moment i'll call on the leader
to present this item
again members you know all about the
hands up function
please make sure that you use that and i
do appeal to you
to keep your points clear and succinct
in order that we finish and get through
the business leader
please present your report thank you
thank you chair really quickly members
this is to the purpose of the report is
to establish a planning policy working
group
to consider and inform the work being
undertaken on developing the
local development plan review and
supplementary planning documents
are set out in the local development
scheme i thought for ease and quickness
rather than populate the recommendation
chairman
is that's a planning policy working
group of up to six members be
established
from uh from my position as the leader i
would like to
suggest that we have uh four independent
members and two conservatives are
democratically alliance group members
and that is my proposal that the group
is made
for independence and two conservatives
are one-on-one
do i have a second or please second did
cancer carly maze
thank you right so that members
has been the motion has been seconded
for
further discussion uh leader do you have
the four names available
chairman i actually wasn't going to
suggest it because it's been dropped on
the other members and they may want to
populate it later when they establish
with the officer
if mr dodson um think that's okay or
or um miss holmes mrs holmes that we can
do that
i can give you the names of the
independents if you wish
but i think it would be unfair because
councillor chana
hasn't been able to uh speak or debate
on this so i'd take
guidance from mr dodson or miss mr
holmes on this please
okay mr uh uh miss homes could you help
us out
are we able to just pass this with six
members and populate it at a later date
i think if we agree this the uh the four
independent members
and uh the two other members yeah i
think chair
it would be just perhaps to clarify who
is going to
to nominate those members at a future a
future date
um and i think you needed to clarify
whether they were going to be
two conservatives or one from the
conservative group and one from the
democratic alliance group and then
perhaps each of the leaders of those
groups that are going to represent could
then confirm at a later date
who they intend to sit on the working
group
thank you for that uh so we have um so
councillor chana first of all are you
are you happy for uh one member
what i was going to say is chairman
could i just ask the lead i was going to
suggest
four two and one so four independents
two conservatives and one democratic
alliance so the planning policy panel
would be increased to seven
well the recommendation is the leaders
uh leader
stanford
i know i'm very fair but i would
actually ask no i won't because it's
inappropriate
if yeah cancer china if the shoe was on
the other foot would you do the same for
us um yeah i think i would on this
because um
we've had working groups before where
we've done it where we have up to number
i know there was one recently the line
was drawn and said no
but um yes i think um
if you're asking if i was in the leader
at that stage and on something like this
i would because this is a whole district
matter
it's a whole planning matter and um it's
very very important
so yeah i would chairman
um oh crikey sorry chairman um
based on that i totally agree and i was
being a little bit flippant so you did
allow me a little bit of leeway
it is important and if
you allow me and the officers allow me i
will increase it to one
if i get a seconder on that
and i will concede that we can have four
independents
two conservatives and one democratic
alliance group
if that is okay to um and i get and i
get it seconded
chairman thompson is
it seems to be a flurry of seconds did
you get a name from that uh
miss bird if you want names from the
conservatives i can give them
uh chairman i got a second thank you
you've got a second
okay chairman we don't need to populate
i think it can be done
by the meeting well i can tell you who
if you like i've got names
i can tell you um i'd like well myself
um obviously and uh counselor maddie
thompson
okay um counselor
counselor helm do you do you wish to
make your nomination now or would you
like to wait
i would like to wait if i please thank
you okay
okay leader if you send your names as
well to mr dodson
uh we've got six of the seven members
can we agree that by ascent
agreed
thank you very much we'll move on to
agenda item
17 revision of meeting dates
leader would you be able to introduce
this report
yeah thank you mr chair members the
purpose of the report is to revise the
schedule statutory annual council
meeting
date should the council and committee
meeting have uh
have provision to go ahead after the 6th
of may 2021
the recommendation is that the schedule
statutory annual date is revised to the
20th of may
2021 and little two is that the
associated
area planning committee dates are
revised as per section
3.7 below before i actually do put the
proposal to recommend this
uh chairman cancer channel made a very
good point at a previous meeting
somewhere
where she actually pointed out it would
have been tight it would have stuck to
the other one
so i thank her for that and i hope
members do actually agree
uh to actually um postpone it and delay
it slightly so that is my recommendation
do i have a secondary
counselor um chairman i don't think
unless mr dodson wishes to come in on
this
um because obviously he doesn't need to
speak but if mr dodson wants to
then i'm more than happy for mr dodson
to speak thank you chair
thank you mr johnson did you want to add
anything i see your head shaking
no okay that's fine uh tara has anybody
else
indicated that they wish to speak uh no
chairman nobody has
okay thank you so members
sorry was that somebody who did no no
apologies chairman i was just saying
i was squeaking agreed so thank you
okay members so uh are we able to agree
that by a cent
agreed
chairman before you move on to the next
next agenda item
and it does relate to it can i just ask
members to take on board the lateness of
the time if members have got serious
questions they want me to answer
i'm more than happy if they put them in
writing i'm just really conscious it
at the time and you've said the
meeting's ending at nine o'clock
and i don't just mean the conservatives
i mean all members because i know the
independents have got questions for me
but i'm
conscious if we've got 15 minutes of
questions
we have got some urgent confidential
business that must get through today
so i would ask members to take that into
account chairman
so members are you prepared to uh write
in with your questions to the leader and
have
a have a response at a later date yes
agree yes
[Music]
[Music]
the whole purpose of having leaders to
the question the questions to the
leaders
is for the residents and our businesses
and other members of the public
to understand uh understand the
questions and understanding the
responses that is what the purpose of
this
is i mean chairman we have a new
administration and i'm sure that the
public could
uh would like to hear would you like to
put your question
would you like to put your question to
the leader please
um chairman i do and i do hope that
other members will be allowed to ask
their questions as well
so i only did
that to offer help to the council i'm
more than happy to sit here for 15
minutes
and be questioned okay so
um leader firstly can i pay tribute to
everyone in our district and in
particular the volunteers who have been
involved in the rollout of the uk-wide
vaccination program
leader on the 14th of january you wrote
to the government expressing your
support
for small modular nuclear reactors given
that it appears we are the only district
council that has endorsed this
technology would it surprise you if such
technology was scoped in our district
and for clarity and for the benefit of
our residents can you please confirm
what your policy is with regards to
nuclear energy
and our district thank you very much
leader um i
to be honest with you councillor fluker
you actually went in and out i don't
know if anybody else heard you properly
but i was
still i'm straining to hear you you mean
my policy
or the council's policy i represent the
council
the council made the decision i didn't
make the decision
so the council's policy was and the
letter went out according to the
council's decision
council of luca chairman
i'll argue with you councillor fluker
you you
will allow me to speak and then when i
take a breath and hand it back but
it is not a question and answer
participation
you can ask me a question i've answered
it i don't have to keep coming back to
you
i don't think the leader has asked the
last piece of the question but
anyway
did you not hear me i didn't hear it all
so if you now want to ask that second
part of the question
then please do so if i can answer it and
i hear it i will
okay so for clarity and for the benefit
of our residents can you please confirm
what your policies with regards to
nuclear energy
and our district thank you no i will not
clarify what my personal view is because
i represent the residents
and it goes to the council where it is
debated
by all members and a policy is then
written
and agreed at council i will not be put
in
any corner or pigeonhole to answer
about nuclear power i am the leader of
the council and i attend meetings with
an open mind and i listen
to the the debate and it is not
my there's no way i'm going to start and
do that sort of thing council fluke so
i'm
very sorry to disappoint you but i thank
you for your question
okay the question has been answered
counselor thompson
oh apologies chairman i didn't realize i
was next um
can the leader tell me if um now that
the barges uh the fees for the key
are quite considerably reduced and i
understand the reasons why that happened
um but does she have a policy for where
the cost of dredging is going to come
from because
this is really important to them to
actually be able to leave and come back
to the key
thank you um thank you for your question
councillor thompson
no we don't have a policy at the moment
oh i don't the council doesn't
but i'm sure the officers will be
looking into that on the back of the the
back of the
february the 23rd finance meeting
so if there is an officer who can
actually answer that
i'd be grateful but if not then we will
have to come back to you later
thank you for the thank you thank you
very much tara
any other questions i heard is there an
officer is there an officer that can
answer
mr dodson are you able to answer that
sorry councillor thompson we'll get back
to you councillor thompson
okay uh tara has anybody else indicated
that they wish to speak
oh yes chairman councillor mrs chandler
councillor helm cancer
i i did put my hand down and i was
before the other two
um i didn't realize that the leader was
going so i did
raise and lower my hand because i
thought i was going to speak next i was
next
okay i'll take you then councillor thank
you very much chairman
i was pleased to read in the one team
newsletter about the major piece of work
that has been developed on council
equality and diversity
and inclusion strategy i understand that
the officers natasha brown luke daly
along with josh vulture have been
working together to develop the new
strategy
which will be aligned to our corporate
plan i'm sure like me the leader is
pleased that the strategy
will focus on our workforce and also in
our communities to ensure that the
council
is meeting its objectives it'll be
interesting to see how these progress
i personally would like to commend the
officers and they come out so
in committing to this work i was very
pleased earlier in the meeting
that other members wanted to support
these kind of values so that's very
welcome
that they've expressed those things
earlier as from someone from the lgbtq
plus community i really do appreciate
that this work is happening
a lot of people do not understand how
much harder it is for someone from this
community
to grow up in a rural area rather than a
city
where it can be easier to access support
i know when i was younger i went through
a lot of personal struggle
now if we can support our communities in
any way to ensure that people do not
have to
face the same issues people from diverse
backgrounds i know from my
own experience can feel very isolated
i'm pleased that the strategy is going
to to incorporate inclusion
and the council ensuring it creates an
environment where everyone feels welcome
and valued as many of you know my own
personal experience as a counselor over
the last two years
has at times been some of the most
stressful of my life
my question to the leader is does she
herself support these values and does
she feel that something that members
need to incorporate
into their own behavior does she hope
that in future
we see members behave in a way that
respects equality
diversity and inclusivity
thank you cancer siddhal what absolutely
excellent quality
quality the question uh and
superb quality um yes we do
and and i thank you for asking it it is
really important that this council
is seen to be um
embracing taking on board um
all aspects of equality and diversity
and um you'll be pleased to know um i
have actually looked into this
and i'm so happy that this council is
going to bring a report
to another committee in i think two
months time because a lot of work has
been done on this
um councillor siddal and i'll just read
a little bit
of the information that i've gathered
and
the people that you've mentioned the
officers have been collaborating and
working on
the new equality diversity and inclusion
strategy
which will be aligned to the corporate
plan which we obviously passed earlier
members so thank you for that
this strategy will not only focus on our
workforce but on our communities
it's not just councillors it's our
communities it's our staff it's
everybody we know who should be treated
with respect
there is also to be set objectives to
make sure that we are meeting our
priorities and i think that's one for
councillor bell because she always wants
to quantify something
with a key performance indicator or such
as like that's the bell don't you
and so gets loaded targets
smack is that comes later on in the park
um councillor bell
both our existing policy and our
strategy going forward are very much
aligned
to the equalities act 2010 but we've
also incorporated
inclusion into our strategy with regard
inclusion
focus will be both on our workforce but
also external communities and
members as i said there is a paper it's
excellent coming to council it's a
fantastic strategy
it's um it's uh hang on a minute
it's a present 12 pages long i've had a
read of it
and i'm absolutely over the moon with
the progress this council is making
and cancer siddha i can only apologize
um on behalf of myself
because i can do this without having to
have the bucket of the council
that you have been treated this way
since you as a council at
this district council and hopefully our
corporate plan
i know it will i think the behaviour
is more supportive understanding
and that we can move forward in a
positive way and thank you for that
question
it's really nice to have a positive
question and not have to put my crush
helmet on
so thank you and mr mr
chairman thank you very much indeed
leader uh councillor channel
thank you we won't need your crash
helmet for this um
one it's just a follow-up from the last
question um well at the last meeting
the one before sorry fourth of feb i did
ask you a question about the parish
council forum and you kindly said
you felt it was a good idea and you
would check the constitution in terms of
reference
may i ask if you've done that but also
maya go a bit further
and ask wouldn't it be sensible for
something like that
to all be on mod.gov i am aware i think
some members are having trouble
accessing various things and wouldn't it
be best if
everything was on mod.gov so we could
all sort of get into things like that
and certainly something like the parish
council forum has agendas
and business that we ought to be aware
of so when we do go to parishes we can
answer questions if they ask us about
things that occurred at the forum
thank you leader yes yes i did i did
contact an officer and i'm sorry i
haven't come back with the answer if i'd
known he was going to ask the question
again for follow-up i would have done so
councillor channel
um the officers are listening uh to this
meeting
can you can you please look into doing
that i'm sure you can accommodate what
council channels just said it's
i'm more than happy to do that and it's
really important because we are going to
work more cooperatively and together
not just at district and parish councils
but essex county councils etc
going further and further afield for
cooperative cooperation
i think that can be done cancer china so
thank you very much because that is
definitely working together for the
benefit of this council
so thank you mr dodson's got his hand up
mr chairman
mr dodson thank you chairman just to say
i thought that had been done
and added to mod gov but but yes of
course
we will make that happen as we're we're
looking at um
populating that library on modgov to
make sure the
information is there for members thank
you thank you councillor helm
when i put my hand down
and i can always do my question in
writing to the leader and copy everybody
thank you very much thank you councillor
hale
thank you very much and yes thank you
for that any other any other
questions tara
no chairman i can see thank you i'll
move on then
this is to agenda item 19. business by
reason
of special circumstances considered by
the gender to be urgent
i have none therefore i'm going to move
to
agenda item 20 which is exclusion of the
press and public
and i move that under section 100 a
of the local government act 1972
uh the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business
on the grounds that they involve the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraph
three of part one and schedule 12a of
the act
and this satisfies the public interest
do i have a seconder for that
thank you very much so uh members of the
public this is where we
uh thank you very much for your
attendance this evening
uh but we now have to go into private
session and that has now been agreed
so uh thank you very much for listening
and good evening
and tara could you tell me when the
streaming has stopped please
you